johnny decides
um rather than do this
he's going to increase each monthly
deposit
by two percent
he's going to increase each monthly
deposit by two percent so he's not going
to keep on putting 100 in
the first increase is uh
in the in the second month so the first
time he gives 100 the next time he's
going to give 100 times
plus 2 percent and the next one 100 plus
2 percent two percent again and so on
okay so then they want us to build the
series again find an expression instead
of a of n they call it b of n
and then find the value after 24 months
okay so let's have a go at this
and this is tricky because
um
this approach is not going to work okay
what's going wrong i'm going to get rid
of this i need some more space
let's build it from scratch this time
because this is where it gets different
and it's either this is how the last or
second last question in a paper so it's
meant to be hard
we're talking instead of a's we've got
b's okay so
b1
he still puts in his first amount just
like he did before
okay and he still gets the same amount
of interest that hasn't changed
okay but what happens next month
he's going to take this amount right
that's b1
and then he's going to put in a new
deposit and then all of that will get
interest okay but the thing is his new
deposit isn't the same size as his first
deposit right it's a hundred
and because it's two percent bigger i
multiply by
1.02 right
and all of that gets interest
okay so
let's just simplify out that terms
101.0025
squared it's got two lots now
and then this is the second deposit he
made here on the end
okay
b3
i'm going to build it the same way right
so it's the previous amount
plus a new deposit
but this deposit is bigger again it's
two percent bigger right so it'll be a
hundred times what
if it's if it's two percent larger
another time right
i multiply it by 1.02 to make it two
percent bigger once so i'll do it again
1.02
squared
okay and then all of that
gets its interest
okay so now i'm going to substitute out
for my b2 so i've got this
100 which was his first deposit it's got
three lots
then i've got his second deposit which
was a bit bigger but it's got less
interest on it
okay and then i've got the most recent
deposit
which was the biggest deposit of the lot
see that's the 1.02 squared but has the
least amount of interest on it
now this is confusing for us right
because as you start to build the series
you can see it's not quite as simple as
it was before okay
now in my um in my working i think just
to be sure i did b4
okay because this is unusual for us
right it's got some different things in
it so what would happen well i'll skip a
line i'll just go immediately to what
it's equal to
that first lot right it's gonna get one
more lot of interest so
four lots of interest
then this next one
which was bigger by two percent
gets another lot of interest
then this one
will get another lot of interest
and then
he'll have his last most recent and
largest deposit
namely it's got
three lots of that two percent increase
plus
one lot
of interest okay i'm trying to get
across to you what each bit is so that
you're not just mindlessly putting all
these indices together but you know what
each bit means okay
so what's b of n
um you can see you can actually still
take out a factor of 100. so that's good
100
out the front okay
what is the um what's the first one
after you take the factor of 100 out
well
it wasn't bigger it just got the
interest on and on and on how many lots
of interest would it have
well
this first one had one lot of interest
and after the second month i have two
lots interest every month it's getting
one lot so after n months it'll have
n lots of interest on it
okay
but the next one right
it's got less interest but it starts out
bigger right so it starts out bigger by
two percent i'm putting that one there
because um
it means i can skip a multiplication
zone and it'll be useful for me later
when i'm counting
but it's got one lot less of interest so
that's n minus one see that
okay the next one
it's bigger to start with so that's the
1.02 squared
but again it's been in there for less
amount of time so it's got less interest
on it namely
n minus 2 lots of interest okay
and then the series goes on what will
the last one be
look at the pattern we've built this is
why it's so important to do this part
right the last part will be the biggest
of all okay in terms of how big it was
when it started this number here 3
and this number here 2 and this number
here 1 okay indicates that this will be
1.02 to the power of
n minus 1 right
you can see it's always one short of
what b is okay
and then it's still got one lot of
interest on it
okay we're almost there now this is why
i tried to draw out the fact that when
you're thinking about your first term
whichever way you look at it when you
look at it forwards or backwards your
first term is going to have some ends in
it okay it's either going to have this n
or it's going to have this n okay you
can't avoid it but that's okay right
this is a gp
and its a is its first term is well
big term we can start at the front we
can start at the end it doesn't matter i
guess i'll pick this one because it's a
bit simpler than this one it's only got
one determinant so here's my a
okay watch the end crucially important
okay
what's the ratio
now we're used to things just going i've
got one lot now i've got two now i've
got three what's happening
as you go from one to another
you get an extra lot of 1.02
but then you get one less of this
interest right 1.025
so you're multiplying by 1.02
but you are dividing at the same time by
1.0025
of course if i started this a at the
other end this would be upside down
because i'm going in a different
direction
how many terms
b1 has one term
b2 has two terms
b3 has three terms i think b of n and
you can count it out actually this is
why i put the ones in there right i've
got one here then two three four five
all the way up into m so they're m terms
so therefore when i put this into my uh
gp formula my sum formula okay i've got
the 100 still hanging out the front
times my a which has an n in it but
that's okay
times r
which is this fraction
all to the power of n
minus one
okay
and that's all divided by
um r minus one which is
this
whatever that is okay
now i think i actually wrote down what
it is because it'll make our fraction
just a little bit neater but it's a
weird fraction
like 400 and something
okay what have i got
now
this hundred have to think about uh
that's sorry out front i'm thinking
about this because we can make this a
little neater so you've got 1.025 to
parameter
you also have 1.025 to the power of n
here right but it's it's dividing so
when i multiply this by this what you'll
be left with is
1.02 to the power of that you see how
those two are cancelling out
and then this just comes along on the
interview so i've got 1.0025
absolutely
he got two ends there that's a bit weird
it does make it very hard to solve if
you were trying to find out an n but the
question we're asking for is after a
certain amount of time okay now i should
just finish off this fraction down the
bottom ends up being
7 on 401 if you chuck into your
calculator
okay
so that 401 i'll just put at the top
on 7.
and that's all the hard leg work okay
now i think the very last question is so
therefore tell me how much does he have
what's the value of b when n is
24 so after two years okay and all you
have to do is take your 24 and chuck it
in here and here you chuck it in two
spots which is a bit unusual compared to
what we usually do but it still works
okay and the numbers still check out be
careful the thing you have to be
thankful for is this
okay